is your Mac running annoyingly slow when
it used to be super fast well mine is it
is really bugging me it needs a tune-up
so I decided to share a set of tips
tricks and settings which are all
completely free and you don't need to
download anything to speed up your Mac
and make it run like new or even better
let's start out by going into your
system settings now some of these are
going to be pretty simple you might know
them While others are going to get more
in depth the first thing I want you to
do is go to your battery section now
here we have some energy modes and I
would go into this on battery setting
and I would make sure that it is not
turned on low power mode if you're
having issues now for some Macs like the
Mt MacBook Air low power mode still
gives you good performance but for the
M1 MacBook Air it cuts it down to about
half which you don't want if you needed
to run fast now on sub Max you will also
see a high power mode and if you're
running on battery and you want the best
performance you want to make sure to
toggle that now here's a bonus tip if
you want your Mac to feel faster you can
actually make it so it doesn't do these
slow animations when you're opening up
Windows and applications that just adds
extra delay go to your desktop and dock
settings and over here you can actually
uncheck anime opening applications I'll
turn off the slow Genie effect and let's
try this out way quicker and how about
opening up an app here
bam and no extra animations for the next
one everybody knows that you should
periodically restart your Mac but I'm
terrible at that and I only do that when
it is running extremely slow but there
is a way to fix that open up your
terminal app and here type in sudo space
PM set space repeat space restart and
then here you could select which days of
the week you want it to automatically
restart so here I have one selected for
every day you could just type in M for
Monday if you wanted to restart once a
week and then I have these zeros here
it's military time so at midnight on
Monday it would restart so it's ready
and fresh for me after that you hit
enter put in your password put in your
password and done I never have to think
about restarting ever again now if you
want to see what your schedule is type
this in hit enter and then right here
you see admin midnight every day we are
restarting and to clear it is easy just
type in this hit enter and fam now you
are back to factory settings to see a
full list of commands type in man PM set
and then here you can actually look and
there are so many things that you could
do with this but with that another thing
that really slows down Max especially
after you've had them for a while are
your login items go into your settings
and type in login into the search and
open up this setting now look at mine
right here no wonder it is running slow
at the top these these are the
applications that open at login every
single time even if you restart I do not
need Android file transferred to open up
automatically same thing with Mandu I
could do that when I actually need it so
get rid of all the junk that you don't
need and then below very important
background apps and tasks for example
this go to meeting is allowed to run in
the background even when I closed it I
do not want that and even these great
apps that I really like when I close
them I want them to shut off and what
the heck is this thing Febreze Lane no I
don't want this stealing my performance
so shut off everything you don't need
now one of the biggest reasons your Mac
will slow down is not having enough RAM
and that could be for multiple different
reasons as you can see I'm using 25 gigs
out of my 30 E2 with zero swab but if
you have a Mac that doesn't have a lot
of ram well chances are you're going to
be slowing down and apple charges an arm
and a leg for their Ram so I can see why
our Ram comparison videos have been so
popular because you want to know if it's
worth it now we have shown that the
eight gigabyte models with low storage
are a lot slower than the 16 gig
especially with the M2 Chip and if
you're multitasking the performance
difference could be massive not only
that but your whole system could be slug
is taking a long time even just to
change web browsing tabs so here's how
you can speed up your Mac if you have a
low amount of ram in the activity
monitor you could see if you are using
any Swap and that will tell you right
away that you're getting some slowdowns
and looking at mine check out all these
Google Chrome helpers when your Mac's
been running for a long time sometimes
stuff just gets stuck in the background
and you can have all sorts of junk
taking up your RAM so go back into your
terminal and type in pseudo Purge we are
going to hit enter put in the password
and then right away it's gonna start
clearing out things that you don't need
and with that you have to make sure that
you're not maxing out your SSD because
if you're getting close to full ssds
actually slow down and then your system
can't write things that don't have
enough RAM onto your SSD or it will just
go way slower so go into your settings
application go to General and then hit
storage settings and as you guys could
see my one terabyte SSD is almost full
now there's a couple things that you can
do you can store items in iCloud but I
would suggest uh taking a look and
checking out where you have a ton of
stuff so for documents here I have 700
gigs click on that little I and you get
this pop-up here that will show you in
the order of how large these files are
just everything is all over your hard
drive you can also look at your
downloads look at this older than the
year old I don't need this junk you can
actually click on it hold down shift
select multiple things to delete and
there's also a file browser where you
can get a little bit more detailed so
make sure you have extra space
especially if you have a 256 gig SSD now
if your internet is being slow I have a
few tips and optimizations for you the
first one is to make sure you don't have
a bunch of junk happening in the
background for example go into your
settings type in iCloud and then open up
this page right here Apple has been
putting a lot of things on by default
which didn't used to be on by default I
have iCloud Drive turned on I used to
have that turned off so you can actually
optimize some things if you want some of
the features but with that you're going
to be syncing all sorts of stuff in the
background and even worse photos now I
turned that off because it was eating up
so much space on my Mac and slowing down
my internet and just doing stuff in the
background so every picture I take on my
phone my iPad that all gets downloaded
automatically to my machine so go
through this list disable this along
with other programs that like to just
run in the background now with that you
need to optimize your Wi-Fi settings and
almost Nobody Does this or go over to
where you see your Wi-Fi little icon and
hold down the option button on your
keyboard and then click it this gives
you a full readout of what is actually
happening and look at this I am
connected to 2.4 gigahertz right here
not the five gigahertz much faster Wi-Fi
connection and look at our rate 144
megabit per second that is sad now most
modern routers they'll give you one
Wi-Fi connection named your IP name
right there we have Thrive and it will
automatically determine what it thinks
is best in this case it is not doing
that I would suggest looking up what
your router's login is for the settings
uh you should have the info on the
bottom of it and login as well uh and
then go into your wireless settings
right here and and then split the
network so that you can connect to the
faster one and if you're far away and
the signal is bad your Mac will still
switch to the better one and this is
especially important if you have a newer
Wi-Fi 6 e-router like the one that I
bought because I found that it would
connect to 6E when it was much slower
than the 5 gigahertz and with that you
need to adjust these settings right here
almost nobody touches their Auto joins
and I connect it to the XFINITY hotspot
and then sometimes I check and it
automatically connects to that which is
way slower so you want to actually click
on here and disable auto join and the
same thing for other ones for example if
I have a slow Network like the 2.4
gigahertz disable the auto join so it
joins to the faster one and the last one
is to speed up search I love using
search I type in a couple things hit
enter and then whatever I need opens up
and same thing with finder but if you
see that it's just not working well it's
not finding your files you need to go
into your settings go into type in Siri
and Spotlight and then over here you can
go into Spotlight privacy now this seems
weird but what you can do is hit this
plus select your hard drive or maybe an
external drive hit choose and this is
going to prevent it from indexing in the
background so once we do that we can hit
done and then open it again remove that
and then that is going to force your Mac
to re-index your computer find all of
your files and make your search much
quicker and more accurate so hopefully
those settings tips and tricks helped
you out will help your Mac run as
quickly as it was brand new if you have
any other tips you can comment down
below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right up there and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
thank you